welcome to another low angle video why
are we
here we're here because this you
remember this you should it's a
character on this channel practically
this over here is do we give this a name
I think we gave this a name anyway this
is the studio trainer QA PC which I've
powered on probably about half a dozen
times in my life
but I still care for her and the reason
why she is significant is because today
we are going going to be testing Hazel
so this is a bit of a series of videos
that if you missed the last one you
might not know what I'm talking about
last one will be linked up there here
right never get the corner right uh my
name is Cho by the way and I'm making a
game engine
boom right so I'm also using a different
lens today so check this out you guys
like this wide view 16 mil baby and the
reason why by the way is because I used
to use this guy this is a I really like
this lens like this is my favorite lens
it's like a Sony G Master really like
great lens but then just one day just
stopped working like this is what I
filmed or used to film up until about 2
months ago the majority of my videos on
but then like it stopped working like
electronically stopped working meaning
like no autofocus no like aperture that
I can adjust just like doesn't even
recognize this lens and I tried it on
multiple camera bodies not so I got to
like I don't know go through warranty or
something probably it's about it's
probably about 2 years old and then so
I've been shooting most of my videos on
this lens which is a Sigma 35 mil 1.4
but then I kind of just wanted to be
able to pull it out you know for this
video so now I can go between 35 mil and
16 mil I apologize if none of you cared
but I just wanted to share that with you
I also think that this new focal length
is going to like reveal parts of the
studio that no one has ever seen before
so hopefully that won't be a bad thing
um so let's talk about this computer a
little bit I think there was like like I
made a video about hazel QA um I don't
remember exactly when that was but it's
kind of interesting because now we
actually get to kind of put all of this
to the test because I didn't I didn't
kind of use this as much for the
previous release and primarily the
reason for that was because we had Tim
now I know a lot of you asked what on
Earth happened to Tim Tim used to be a
member of Studio Cho he used to work he
actually used to like sit and work right
here now a printer is
there so what happened to
well he quit he decided that working on
Hazel was such an experience that he
just quit this entire industry and now
he works in sales so yeah that's um I'm
going to try and avoid doing that in the
future to Future employees and I'm sorry
but that that is what happened like I'm
not making this up so yeah Tim is gone
we're definitely going to miss him uh I
did not fire him he resigned so I just
want to get that cleared but that what
what that means is that now I can't be
like hey Tim
um you know just test all of Hazel in
retrospect that may have been one of the
the things that pushing towards quitting
but nevertheless I kind of need to have
a little bit more of like a QA strategy
for hazel I mean either way it would
have been heading towards this direction
but I need to have a little bit more of
a solid QA strategy for hazel that
doesn't involve telling one person to
just go through and test the entire
engine and so that is why we're going to
have this computer which is going to
kind of go through everything and it's
going to do some automated tests it's
going to just like build commits of the
code make sure everything's compiling
one of the things Tim was working on
before he left was actually an automated
kind of Hazel scene Runner because I saw
this coming not Tim leaving but because
I knew that in the future we're
obviously going to want to not get Tim
to just spend all his time testing
everything but we need an automated
waste so I got Tim working on that and
what he built was some kind of like C
application I believe that will kind of
launch the Hazel runtime that runtime
would then effectively run the Hazel QA
project which is a collection of scenes
that are designed designed for testing
different systems of the engine it would
actually look into the asset pack of
that project to see all the scenes that
were available and then it would just
basically just go through all the scenes
run them for a configurable amount of
time such as 60 seconds then move on to
the next scene inside that asset pack so
it's just a really simple way of us
basically just building like I don't
know as many scenes as we want like say
50 scenes and then having like an
application that just runs each of those
scenes for 50 seconds and then reports
like you know stuff like frame rates and
other metrics as well as like did we
crash or not which is kind of a
preliminary test I would also like it to
you know take screenshots and maybe
publish them somewhere so that someone
like a human could just kind of look at
this and be like all right animation
scene like does that look right and then
at a minimum you know if we kind of get
that process happening for every single
commit that goes into like the
development branch which is the kind of
branch that everyone's features go into
and then obviously like the staging
branch which is the one that we're kind
of preparing for release then that's
going to be great and that's going to
mean that at a minimum you know we're
not going to accidentally just crash all
the time as long as those test scenes
are designed in a good way that actually
does test the majority of the different
you know properties and Systems Hazel
might have then it really should be just
as simple as kind of comparing expected
results versus what we actually got like
now when we ran the test now if you're
just getting started with computer
science and programming and you're
finding it a little bit difficult you
need some help then boy do I have an
excellent free suggestion for you that
is the sponsor of this video
brilliant.org brilliant.org is an
amazing website filled with lots and
lots of really high quality courses on
various DN topics now they have some
excellent computer science courses and
the thing with brilliant is that their
teaching style is extremely clear
concise Visual and engaging it can be
hard to learn some of these topics so
why not make it easier for yourselves by
picking a learning style that suits you
and in my opinion that learning style is
just what brilliant does because having
these widgets that you can play with
getting constantly quizzed so that the
information that you're just learning
now gets properly processed and you
remember it that can be a really
effective way to learn and as you're
seeing it extends into like all of these
advanced math topics which I personally
think greatly benefit from this approach
to learning and here's the thing you can
get started for free they have a 30-day
free trial which you can use to check
out all of the courses they have just go
to brilliant.org Theo link will be in
the description below and if you do go
on to like it brilliant have been nice
enough to offer the first 200 of you 20%
off an annual membership huge thank you
as always to brilliant.org for
sponsoring this video now the thing is
this thing that Tim made uh I actually I
don't have it it's actually on Tim's
Computer well it's on the it's on Studio
Cho's computer technically but it's the
one that Tim used to use at his desk
which I just showed so we're going to
have to just jump on that computer and
I'm going to have to like recover it
because I don't know where it is it
should be somewhere on the hard drive so
we're just going to kind of explore it
and see where Tim left off and um yeah
that's kind of the that's what we're
doing today where we're going to see how
far Tim got with his little test Runner
and whether or not we can just take it
plop it onto this maybe adapt it with
the newest version of Hazel and get some
tests running and I expect that
obviously we're going to have to extend
it a bit from memory because last time
we spoke about this was probably 3
months ago from memory I believe Tim had
it running and iterating through all the
scenes for like 60 seconds I don't know
if things like frame rates were reported
or where they were reported to but at
the minimum I believe it should run and
in fact while we're at it we need to
look at this H this Hazel QA project
because I haven't actually had much of a
look into that I know Peter has I know
Peter's made some kind of physics test
scenes and maybe even some scripting
test scenes for that Hazel QA project
and this Hazel QA project is essentially
like a game we've built with a
collection of scenes which is designed
to test you know everything that Hazel
has to offer every single feature so we
might have like a physics test scene
which is just like a bunch of different
rigid bodies with different properties
there might be like some kind of
Graphics test scene that just like
manipulates Graphics settings there'll
be like an animation test scene that
sets up like a skeletal animation with
whatever other animation features we
might have and tries to play those
animations so the idea is we can just
like look at these and see if the engine
is working as required now a big
downside with this system is obviously
this is just designed to test Hazel's
kind of runtime so like you've made a
scene in Hazel let's hit play Let's see
what happens right this does not test
the edit itself and we don't really have
a solution for that at the moment like
how do we know if we try and add a
component to something is the engine
going to crash at the moment that's like
human testing and that obviously is not
good so we need to kind of come up with
a way to I guess automate editor actions
and run through that but I have plans
for that because well we'll talk about
that in another
video so this is I guess this is going
to be like a typical actually real
devlog because I've just spent like the
last few hours doing something that I
now realize was a a huge mistake mistake
I don't even know why I decided to go
down this rabbit hole and so I guess
I'll talk about it I'll talk about what
I've been doing on this QA PC here so I
mean we've been talking about automation
right we've been talking about how we
can get this stuff tested automatically
because I can't sit here I mean no one
on the team can really sit here just
testing this stuff over and over again
and some of the tests are so kind of
black and white like for example does
this compile like we don't need a human
testing that that's very like yes or no
of course if you're dealing with like
some more advanced things like or does
the physics feel feel right does the
graphics like look correct like that can
be a little bit harder to automate but
some of these things like really should
just be done automatically and so I'm
sitting here kind of thinking about how
this is going to work and you know we
have a development branch that contains
all of the commits kind of from the team
that come together you know into this
Dev Branch I think I should probably
take the time at some point to formally
explain uh and maybe even have a diagram
you know on the website or something
just you know all these kind of Branch
structures and how they work cuz I I
feel like I always keep repeating myself
but anyway the idea is every time
someone does commit into this Dev Branch
I kind of want to run my automated tests
on there and like step one is just
really just making sure it compiles in
all the configurations and Reporting any
build errors like that that's step one
so then how do I do that because I need
to know obviously when we have new
commits coming in to the repository
whenever someone pushes to our git
repository on GitHub like I need to You
Know download that commit basically pull
that commit and then build the code and
eventually run tests on it so there are
a few different ways that I can do that
the first thing that came to mind was
just having some kind of CI which stands
for continuous integration running on
the actual GitHub like repository
because there's this thing called GitHub
actions that lets you kind of set up
things to happen when there are certain
events in the repository but the reason
why I don't think that's a good fit is
because I need to run this stuff on this
computer it this isn't like a web app or
some kind of like you know simple case
of just like building and that's it and
making sure this compiles like no I need
to run tests on this I need to report
things like performance and frame rate
and memory usage like this has to be a
real kind of computer running this and
not just a real computer running this
but also a computer whose Hardware I can
control because at the moment we have an
RTX 360 in here but like there's a
gtx650 lying around in the office we
have some AMD cards as well like we need
to actually make sure that Hazel is
getting tested properly on all of these
different cards because most of the
development team is obviously running
much higher powered cards like I have a
380 Peter has a 370 the majority of you
know actual real world people who play
games at least according to the steam
Hardware survey seem to have either a
3060 or a 1650 so we clearly need to
make sure that we're accurately kind of
testing Hazel's performance on those
cards and then reporting this stuff so
that we we know you know over time is
this engine getting faster is it getting
slower across like the huge number of
tests that we have to run so my point is
this isn't something that a server can
execute this is something that needs to
happen on a real computer with a real
graphics card in a fully kind of
controllable way and so that's why this
QA kind of I guess it's also like a CI
machine now but like this this computer
that's what it's for so then I'm like
okay well you know if this if this is
the computer that needs to run that
stuff then uh I guess GitHub actions
goes out the window at least as far as
I'm aware I don't know maybe I'm missing
something that's always possible you
guys can always let me know in the
comments below and also so like I I
don't want to go too in depth into the
the solution here as well which is why
like I'm not showing you my screen at
the moment because I don't know like I
never know how to make these videos like
it seems to me like it would be better
for me to kind of show this when it's
actually working in full because I
imagine that like it's going to change a
bit you know as I go through this and I
don't know if you want to like hear me
talking about all these things that I
might do and you know all of this
discussion V is actually just showing
you hey guys I did this thing I like I
don't know how to make these devlogs
honestly I keep saying that but I just
have no idea what what I'm doing please
let me know if you're enjoying this kind
of well this video I guess which is
mostly me just talking about what's
going on so back to what is going on
then this computer has to be made aware
every time there is a new commit going
into that GitHub repository so my next
kind of thought was well I can just use
a web hook maybe now a web hook just
allows you to put in a URL into GitHub
into your repository settings and then
when like a subset of events occur on
that repository GitHub will simply you
know call that URL with some payload we
talked about this in the uh
documentation website video which I'll
have linked up there we used a web hook
in fact we still use a web hook on docs.
Hazel engine.com so that every time
there is an update to that repository
containing documentation it will rebuild
the kind of static website uh the thing
is though that website obviously that
documentation website that's hosted on
like a a Linux server like that is is
that's not like a computer in the office
that's an actual VPS so I was like well
um I don't know like what should I do
should I maybe set this up to be a web
server and so I ended up installing
engine X on Windows which uh I don't
know it just feels wrong honestly I
ended up like forwarding my ports I
ended up discovering that apparently
engine X can't run in like just HTTP
like it has to have an SSL certificate
to be used externally so not just Local
Host and then I was kind of going
through like bot and trying to set that
up like I would for a server and then I
was like man what am I doing like this
is like this is hugely annoying like for
so many reasons like I mean first of all
I don't even have a static IP address
for this office like it's just a dynamic
IP so I'm going to have to update it
every now and then I don't even know how
often that kind of external IP address
is going to change but also it's
extremely annoying to to deploy this
because this is something that has to
run well hope I I like I'd want this
automation basic Bally to run on more
than just this computer why because as I
this is just one computer what if I want
it to run on the AMD computer or what if
I wanted to run on that 1650 computer
because this is this is the RTX 360 I
mean the like the 1650 doesn't even have
a computer it's just lying lying down
there and I suppose I could install
multiple graphics cards in one computer
just to not have to build so many
computers and just have it kind of
Select which device to use but either
way it would obviously be nice to just
have an out of the box solution that
doesn't require you to set up a web
server and forward ports and do whatever
on Earth else to just simply run this so
I was like well why don't why don't I
just you know do this the simple way and
just poll GitHub to be like hey man do
you have a new commit on this Branch
like yes I guess that's not as cool as a
little push event that's just like hey
man you you got a new commit but this is
just so much easier and it means that
really all it is is is a self-contained
kind of script that just runs like on
any computer you want it can just be in
the Hazel repository just clone Hazel
and you can be like this computer's now
a CI machine like this computer is now
capable of running automated tests and
retrieving new commits by itself like
that is just so much easier so much more
portable like why on Earth would I set
up a web server so that was my day um
that was yeah so what I've done at the
moment is like I'm using again I'll
probably show this like when it's done
but I'm using something called git
python which is like a git package for
python which just gives you like a nice
API that you can use to run git commands
and I've just got it like looking at the
the local repository here connecting to
like the remote seeing what the latest
kind of you know commit hash is on that
remote and just comparing it to like
what the current head is you know on the
local repository and then if they're
different well I'm going to run my
little build script which I have here
which is just simply going to you know
call setup up which initializes all the
sub modules and does some other stuff to
generate the actual project files for
hazel using premake and then it's going
to just call Ms build to actually build
like the Hazel solution in debug release
and disc configurations so I've got that
basically working uh I'd like to kind of
clean it up and there's a lot of kind of
well what if this happens what if that
happens the git python um package uh the
documentation is atrocious I don't know
maybe I'm the problem but like I have
had to guess certain things because I've
searched for them and they're actively
not there it's like they'll tell you
like what functions or like variables
are available on a certain object and
then half of them just aren't there the
API reference is like seemingly half
complete unless I'm just an idiot and
I'm not reading it properly somehow but
anyway that's um that's where I'm at
right now I'm going to end this video
here there'll probably be another video
next week I'm trying to just kind of
make I guess more frequent videos just
cuz I always feel like there's a lot to
talk about about and I hope that this is
interesting to some of you I feel like
this is this is going to get real met
now but I feel like there's this kind of
pressure sometimes on YouTube to try and
show exciting stuff and like again I
could wait like a month or whatever
while I set this up behind the scenes
and then be like here's a video of how I
did this from start to finish but the
thing is I don't know I just feel like
you know life is about the journey and
these videos are the journey as of right
now this this this is not done so being
able to discuss it without actually
knowing the correct you know solution is
kind of cool and my hope is that you
guys kind of feel a little bit more
involved with the project you get more
frequent updates as to like what's going
on with hazel and the team I really
wanted to show you in this video the
actual Hazel QA project which I ended up
getting off of Tim's Computer well
actually it wasn't even like Ju Just on
Tim's Computer he actually pushed it
like into our kind of Studio Cho GitHub
but yeah that project is huge and covers
so many different systems and little
kind of parameters that Hazel has so
maybe next video I will show you guys
the kind of Hazel QA project that we're
going to end up hooking up into this
automation test and then I still have to
write that kind of test Runner
application the thing that will actually
automatically load up that Hazel QA
project play it in the runtime and kind
of iterate through all the scenes to
test everything and Report the metrix so
we haven't even begun digging into this
if I might say one more thing before I
end this video that probably should have
ended a while ago it's going to be that
making these videos it's kind of showing
almost to me just how complicated some
of this stuff is because sometimes like
to me it's almost like ah yeah just get
like you know some automated testing
going that'll be a piece of cake one
video done but now that I'm actually
kind of going into this in detail and
like vlogging about it as I go through
the process it's like it's showing me
that actually like if I was to explain
every step here like it's really not
that simple so yeah Welcome to the Real
World I'm being real now